dude that the footage in Italy people
passing out what was the footage in
Italy the footage in Italy of like
lockdown all that [__] everything's
going crazy
I was like how'd they get that on camera
how'd they get that
[Music]
welcome back to careful boys we are very
careful boys and today we are going to
share what our most controversial
opinions are oh damn interesting come on
Steve don't do this
Nick feels about anything yeah opinions
what are our most controversial opinions
well yeah what are something that I
haven't shared yet you like it like I
want the death penalty yeah
I sometimes people need to die why is
that controversial it's because they're
bad guys but what if we what if they you
know because DNA DNA evidence found out
they weren't that bad
try to resuscitate them but they're dead
that's the problem that's why but I I
think he's saying you got to make for
sure are you are you more lenient or is
the death penalty more lenient on people
that were incarcerated pre-dna Tech
because that's kind of interesting
anyone caught now probably is easier to
prove guilty than people caught in like
this yeah I'm saying like if we started
yeah would they make a big nice little
like PSA about it hey criminals just to
let you know we're gonna start killing
[__] so starting in 2023. yeah
and then and then I was like oh [__] I
gotta get all my crimes out of the way
I used to be
um for that but then now I believe
they're demons in human form so we gotta
keep them here as long as possible
locked up in a bottle and because once
they get Unleashed they're gonna
reincarnate a baby and then come back
and do it again yeah yeah that is
controversial that's not that
controversial yeah I just had to we're
looking for really controversial really
controversial get real hot Joe it's a
real hot take because it's like like our
own personal like I'm trying to
understand the question well because I
think controversial it's like what what
do you feel about that like you know if
you just brought up at any party at full
volume everyone's like ah [__] Chappelle
or a lot of people would be like damn
that's what you think oh I have one I
guess yeah okay I I think social anxiety
is a [__] scam dude
what do you mean it's a scam like it
doesn't exist because everyone has it oh
yeah I think everyone has it and I think
it's like it's like putting a disease on
stage fright it's like everyone has
stage bright everybody's afraid to get
judged all the time everyone's afraid to
get judged by what comes out of their
mouth it's a part of life you just have
to talk more and then you'll won't have
as much anxiety some people would be
really upset with you but I'm gonna
hyperventilate you [__] face people have
gotten mad at me about that and I go
okay all right dude I used to always
feel so social anxiety all the time I
didn't know that's what it was called
and you probably still do just keep
exactly are you just [__] just don't
give a [__] when I started honestly when
I started working at Giant Rockets it
forced me to start [__] talking to
people on like yeah conversation like
doing having a job where you're forced
to talk to people because it makes it
easier it does help a time it feels like
repetition helps yeah yeah
there's more bad therapists than there's
good ones dude I agree really I agree
what makes you think yeah because
because I I don't know what it is either
people aren't [__] listening yeah so
they're goddamn therapists because I'm
like you're the exact same like you you
like you haven't made any type of
[__] shift in your [__] life like
like I'll see people they're like yeah
man you know I've been going to therapy
for a minute I go you still suck you
know what I mean like like that I know
it's controversial but I'm gonna say
like I mean
they're not working at four years later
the same person and I guess I'm not
trying to say I'm all high and mighty
but like when I went through anger
management like I said like I've had
three different anger management
teachers right I started going when I
was like 15. and I stopped when I
retired when I was like 20 something
yeah that's a long time that's a long
time but you put in the work I put in
the work but like also like like you
know there's a lot to understand like
when I was younger it was it was a
little different as an adult that's when
it like really the seasons of life
change yeah yeah yeah because you gotta
you got to grow up a little bit you know
but you know from me they made
everything about me and like nothing
else like like the [__] that I was like
upset about they were like yeah yeah
cool cool let's narrow it down to you
you know what I mean and I think a lot
of therapists don't do that with their
patients so I think a lot of times
they're like oh it's okay to feel that
way like [__] no it's not yeah like
it's not okay to feel that way you gotta
[__] you know you gotta learn you got
to educate yourself and do for you not
like like [__] what your pops did to you
when you was like 10. cool it happened
it already happened how do we move
forward yeah exactly
and so that's what that's what it really
taught like I feel like because I'm like
because I listen I know a lot of people
that go to [__] therapy and I'm like
dog you ever you ever see a cert of how
to actually become a therapist is it
really easy is it easy it's pretty easy
we got to create a account and log in
and then find the find the buses there's
different licenses right type your email
address twice the difference is this is
what sucks like so like you know how
doctors there's a whole system of
becoming a medical doctor that takes
like 70 years right and then you have to
there's actually like a test a oath like
you have to do all these things and then
you start practicing well in therapy
therapy right you have counseling you
have Psychiatry you have people with so
many various experiences degrees and
whatever and if you're just going on a
site to like maybe talk to a one-on-one
therapist or whatever like you really
gotta understand what all of these
things mean like are they mft meaning
like uh marriage family therapy
counselor where do they get their like
certification like it's kind of like
being a fitness instructor so like which
is also very easy exactly it's easy to
[__] get it's not hard unless you're
like oh this guy this person's like got
a clinic they're like one of the leading
members of Like therapy and that's why
and it's not standardized that's the
issue is because there's also different
schools of therapy right like you could
be like a cognitive behavioral therapist
you could be like you know so so one of
the ones I hate is called Hypno uh uh
hypnotherapy they use hypnosis to try to
[__] therapize it I hate that [__] no
they implant [__] things in your mind
but me yeah you gotta you gotta use your
[__] words and I feel like a lot of
times like that's a hard skill too yeah
that's a hard skill and a lot I think a
lot of people aren't necessarily you
know breaking that [__] down like
there's so much information out there
other than your [__] therapist that
can guide you you to to you know walk
into life a lot smoother you know it's
all like the information you're taking
in and it's like yeah this person can go
to therapy every week but also if
they're paying attention to the same
[__] every [__] day yeah then what
the [__] doesn't matter I also think it
goes back on the individual that's in
therapy because the story that they're
telling the therapist is also just one
side it's like once it's in one side
it's their interpretation of what's
happening to them and as they explain to
the therapist it could give a very
skewed view to the therapist right so
that also changes how they give
information back so to Bank off you
that's like okay you go to there because
you had a bad breakup right and you're
telling you're only telling your side
yeah yeah it doesn't make sense if the
other person's not there yeah because
the other person saw some other [__] too
yeah and also you know with them saying
that [__] could probably [__] help
you I don't know I just think there's
just like this weird thing with therapy
now because everyone's like yeah therapy
therapy and everyone's going which is
great I'm glad we're [__]
man you go to college a little bit a
couple times I watch YouTube videos
what's the motivation for a therapist to
not
make you have to keep coming back though
that's what that's another thing too
like what's the yeah why wouldn't if I
cure all the my clients and they never
have to come back then where's my new
set of clients well I mean but I feel
like that will cost I feel like that's I
think ideally you would have a success
case and then they would tell their
friends so each new cured person brings
in three more people what if that person
has no friends well it is kind of but
it's kind of like it's kind of more like
what Nick does right you get your body
right right and then it's something you
keep on having to do so yeah if you went
through some traumatic thing like you
have to keep on checking in keeping that
brain like like oh yeah like your mental
Fitness yeah when I when I had a
therapist for a little bit and I was
going through some [__] and I need to
talk it out
um is it because you're a [__] wife
that was because of their shoe told me
it was my [__] ass self she was like
you're being a little [__] my real wife
is toxic that's what my therapist said
my therapist was like you're a [__]
little [__] you need to get over it and
sometimes you got you need that
sometimes you need that most of the time
but like no that's that's what a hundred
percent but like my good therapist would
told me it was like it's not about you
you [__] idiot pull back right so and
then she would say that and then after a
while she was like yeah I don't think
you can see me real for a little bit and
I was like
am I a bad client like I was like
questioning like am I [__] up so
that's my wife I was like is that normal
and she goes yeah good therapists do
that good therapist would be like yeah
my line is open for you you could always
come back and hit me up yeah but like as
of now I think you're fine you'll be
okay but oh wow but she was like my
Line's open you're good talk to you
later because I also think
if a good therapist really wants to be
good at their job they actually want to
provide value and service and really get
somebody to where they want to be so if
they have someone who is not making any
progress they automatically become like
a dreaded client for sure right so
they're just like [__] this ain't
working out today's video is brought to
you by Warby Parker look at those cool
sunglasses aren't these cool and you
know how I know I made these fit because
I got to get five of them and then
sometimes like on the websites like if
you go to all the different brands a
look like this and you think it's
perfect but it comes too small and you
put on their face or it's way too big or
like this thing doesn't fit and what I
like about Warby Parker is you get to
choose five of your favorite ones and
you try them on put on different outfits
and go oh you know what this one
actually looks and fits good yeah that's
the best part of it is usually you don't
get to try on glasses when you buy it
online and then a lot of them they have
really crappy return kind of like
programs but with Barbie Parker you
could try it out be like oh yeah I look
pretty cool let me get these or like you
know what I don't know about this one I
don't think it fits with my nose so
Warby Parker offers you everything you
need for happier eyes from eyeglasses
sunglasses contact lenses even eye exams
like what's going on in there and you
can shop with them online or in stores
and glasses start at only 95 bucks
including the prescription lenses wow
that's a good deal man try Warby
Parker's free home try on program order
five pairs of glasses to try at home for
free there's no obligation to buy ships
free and includes a prepaid return
shipping label so try five pairs of
glasses at home for free at
warbyparker.com off the Record your lazy
ass doesn't even have to leave your
house at home but then when they have
someone that has gotten some big strides
they're going oh man this is great this
is awesome you yeah that's what you want
to see yeah exactly yeah because I I can
relate that to to being a personal
trainer like I have some clients that
I'm like [__] dude you're not we got to
figure out a way to get you to the next
step right and it's taking a really long
time but it's like okay it is what it is
but it does become frustrating but then
you have some clients that knock it out
the park and you're like great yeah I
don't need to see you as much anymore
you can't live in your life that's you
want to get them to where they want to
be but you want a therapist with no ego
because because then they're like it's
straight up like they're not being
biased or anything like that they're
just like hey this is what it is just
being straight up [__] real for sure
but like what you were saying is like
when a client goes through a therapist
and they have a like a like a great
experience they are definitely going to
be way more willing to talk about it to
other people and be like yo I have this
one therapist that hooked me up they did
such a good job their approach was X Y
and Z and then it becomes like a word of
mouth thing and then they're like okay
cool then it does lead back into their
business so yeah I have a friend he's
like Priestess sex uh successful and
when I was talking to him
he had like pretty traumatic and
physically abusive upbringing by his
parents
and then I was like oh [__] damn that
their dad did this be the [__] I go
there about stuff and then uh so I was
like like do you
um have any like feelings or like
towards your parents and he goes no I
[__] love my parents are the best
parents I've ever had because they they
did the best that they could yeah so
what they did what they did to me is on
them but how I receive and perceive what
they did to me is my responsibility yeah
yeah damn that's [__] crazy because I
grew up with the same thing my
stepfather was [__] crazy but
meanwhile I'll call him [__]
right now you know what we'll get them
on the phone let's get Jerry on the
phone hey Jerry
I'm a beater
you didn't do something I think there's
something dope yeah to where you can
look at a person yeah that caused you
this trauma and meanwhile like you've
grown up in a way to where now you're
like hey that was in the past that's
your benefits
yeah if you feel some type of way about
that person for a really long time and
it it holds you back to doing anything
else that's they have a power over you a
lot right for sure so so imagine it's
like this say say you know in some weird
way I've you know
you know told about my stepfather and
then I was able to get him in prison for
what he did to me when I was a kid then
what yeah yeah I'm still mad at him yeah
you know what I'm saying like the anger
is still there so it's like it might
feel a little better it might feel a
little better but yeah but you still got
to do the work either way you still got
to do the work either way like you're
still going to be upset right that's
just the outside you still have to work
on that [__] either way either way
that's big [__] it is it is big boy
[__] yeah yeah see was that pretty
comfortable
[__] therapy I agree
we should get rid of it
you know what's weird is like why are
controversial things today just truthful
things that people are afraid to say
because people are softer I think or
like they're you know what it is I think
they don't want to hurt people that
that don't think the same way I don't
agree I think that I care about hurting
people anymore look at what just
happened during covet dude
doing each other and [__] you had people
couldn't wait to hurt their someone if
they're doing something they'd rather
your business fail yes exactly and
that's my thing for this my
controversial opinion every one of those
[__] should have a sign on
their lawn saying I was a dumb [__]
100 okay bumper sticker yeah yeah sure
it's [__] signs do you think they you
call these [__] out and they'll you
make this law because there's a lot of
people that haven't they're not owning
it but that's why I want them
all the social media people out there
[__] shame they can't even find it in
their memory when they said these things
yeah like even if you confront them do
you have any people I was shaming her in
kova dude you were saving people
get hard or it was like hey come over
and watch the fights uh Mike Tyson fight
Roy Jones and I was like are you [__]
kidding me I'm like this how dare you I
didn't tell him that buddy yeah
I'm gonna give cover to everybody if you
want to come yeah
none of the lockdowns helped stop any
spreads help help save any lives it was
just a bunch of feel-good [__] you
know I'll never forget I was at a CVS
one time right during Christmas and I
there's this chick standing in front of
me six feet or like whatever I'm
probably three feet away from her and
she turns around looks at me she's like
um we're supposed to be six feet apart I
would like to track her down and say you
were a dumb [__] oh yeah I got one too
I got beef with somebody yeah I was
outside of a Phil's Coffee shop working
on my computer and I was working and
then this guy walks around and he goes
put your [__] mask on and he was like
this tall skinny white dude and then he
walked down he he walked away from me
and I was like what the [__]
I was a dumb [__] and he's walking away
I was like I was like at least I was a
scared dumb [__] during coven exactly
and that's what his pockets and it
wasn't scientific I was just being a
dumbass [__] yeah because you will show
them the science and then they go you
trust the science yeah dude it was it
was interesting watching people just
have this like like try to be this
authority figure of like you know to
tell you what to do and it's like [__]
up like who are you I also like it like
when people are like you know you you're
you're you're when they were calling
people murderers yeah Grandma Killers
most people Killers ever during that
whole thing like murderers yo you know
what people were saying that I didn't
realize how many people didn't know how
like just viruses and
diseases just were it was like you
[__] [__] you know how many people
die from the flu like this way every
year like like yeah they get con you
know they get sick and then they [__]
die and then it's because it spreads
this way everybody knows like I thought
everyone's like duh you're supposed to
wash your hands when you come home from
outside you're supposed to do these
things like duh right but you you know
you know what I blame
I
[Laughter]
don't know why I got so
the people I play
Ed I blame is the educational system
our educational system yeah you're right
dog [__] it is and it may and it like
there's people that have no strong
educational background saying [__] were
you like dog I know how far you got in
school yeah why the [__] are you telling
me what the [__] to do like like who are
you we got eighth grade graduated
[__] like leaders dude like that's
what I'm saying like these people were
like yeah this is this is what's up like
this is what's happening I'm like [__]
what dude that one [__] told us to
wear two masks to make it even more
protection
yeah oh I remember there was a time
that's one of his pockets that's one of
these pockets on my on my Instagram feed
I had some like old buddies that um were
convinced this was early in the pandemic
and I don't know if you guys caught this
but
guys were saying that 5G was causing oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
that was the thing that was going on
that was the thing and uh I think my cup
I have a couple family members that work
in like the 5G like cell phone tower
space I'll quit their jobs no they were
saying that people were destroying 5G
Towers
see I worry how [__] dumb Americans
are oh I mean this is in California but
the funny thing is how do you
differentiate why was 4G okay what did
they know about 4G but what did they
know about 4G to go to go that's cool
because I need that to tell people about
5G
like you wouldn't understand Ryan okay
my radar for the whole code 15 was three
things one our graphic designer uh he
also worked for like the NBA and he told
me I think back in [__] I forgot when
but it was maybe like back in I think
December January before like the March
and April lockdowns he was like hey I
think uh we should all come out with
masks because there's going to be masked
with every single NBA basketball team on
it uh because of this coffee thing I'm
like what what the [__] like it seems so
crazy that something was already so
predestined so I kind of made a little
bookmark there I'm like that's crazy
that he would even know that like or the
entire NBA knows this is this is what
we're gonna do my second one I have a
friend that was a nurse at Cedar Sinai
and he told me uh he doesn't know why
but every single death he puts down uh
it's gonna be 10K for the hospital and
then also
um he's gonna get a certain amount of
like overtime if he worked whatever so
I'm like okay if it's if he's if he's at
the front lines and he's extremely happy
to go to work because he's going to make
three times the amount that he ever did
I'm like because most people it's like
life or money they're like I'll take
life for him it's like the Danger's down
here I'm gonna take the money so that
was like my question mark number two and
the third one was when it was full blown
and homeless people are having a party
in the [__] streets none of them are
dropping down on the floor and they're
like wait
the people with the least amount of
resources should drop us
all be dead like first like like a real
all the deaths are coming from obese
First World countries and oldly old
people yeah and I'm like okay I don't
think this is what it's being paid so so
don't lie be honest with me when it
first popped off the job I think
everyone's scared in the beginning dude
that the footage in Italy
the footage in Italy of like lockdown
all that [__] everything going crazy oh
[Laughter]
yeah I was like how they get that on
camera how'd they get that do you guys
remember uh like New York where there
was all the hospitals and then there
they were showing [__] Mass Graves
and [__] yeah that is scary but it was
look there were people dying in New York
but it was for sure it's a coping death
like Bart's saying they love they love
they made everything in cover death and
they're making money off of it so
they're actually not incentivized to
tell you what happened they're
incentivized to lie yeah and then I
remember when I and then the final thing
was when when I did catch it and then I
remember getting [__] swapped and
[__] and then they're like oh you're
like positive for it and then I was like
okay so like what kind of medicine
they're like you don't have medicine and
I'm like oh what are you doing he goes I
just waited out for two weeks and I'm
like yeah the fact that they were saying
just wait it out everyone just says wait
it out and your body
that's what I thought was interesting
and your body feels nothing yeah and
then I remember day one I'm like all
right I guess time to watch [__]
Karate Kid marathon and I'm gonna turn
it on day one day two I felt good like
in 72 hours I was like oh [__] I think
I'm back to normal I'm like what the
[__] not me I was not I was not you know
what though
how early did you get it though did you
get it early uh no I got the [__] when
it was like the second the second strand
where it was like pretty hardcore I was
down for account for like 10 days so you
know what the most ridiculous [__] was
okay so do you remember when they were
trying to open back up right their game
plan was okay we're all gonna get
vaccinated and then we're gonna have
herd immunity and whatever whatever
right so they got like 20 of the
population vaccinated and then they kept
saying all right guys get your free
vaccinations and then no one really
wanted to get vaccinated and it just
started bullshitting like okay uh we
still got about like so much more
medicine come on and get some free
donuts
free donuts yeah and then all of us
I'll go for hockey tickets they were
like hey we met our goal and it was like
less than 30 percent of the population
actually got vaccinated and they're like
well isn't it great that we have heard
immunity now and I'm all like shut the
[__] up dude you failed at getting
everybody vaccinated a lot of people
were questioning it and now they're
making this argument like okay now it's
not the same potency it's a it's a
weaker but it that's what would have
naturally happened anyway like it that's
what happens when there's like like um
like when the flu was introduced and all
that yeah but we weren't just blindly
trusting the experts Joe I had a buddy I
had a buddy who just got diagnosed with
cancer he had to go to three doctors
before they even knew he had cancer
because the experts you know it's
[__] crazy isn't it
so it was Sweden
Sweden or Finland are one of those
countries right they from the get they
were like Florida they're like we're not
gonna do this We're Not Gonna shut down
our economy We're not gonna do any of
that it's oh and then they all died
that's right yeah the whole country
doesn't exist anymore yeah it blew up
the 5G got it did in Florida the the
month after lockdown they're like yeah
we're not doing this and then they just
oh yeah they just straight over like nah
it was fast Laguna Hills should be wiped
out same with San Clemente they should
all be dead Orange County should be good
oh yeah Orange County extreme
politicization of it because when Trump
was in office remember he was like oh
don't worry I got I got homies and the
big Pharma they're working on a vaccine
and then all the Democrats well you
can't trust that [__] is way too fast
and then when you switch power the same
people that are saying don't trust that
[__] are the same people that are like
get the vaccine I'm like but the
companies are the same yeah it's still
these three companies yeah they still
rushed and I was like wait a minute I
remember his craziest flip-flop I've
ever seen I remember during that time
they had Olivia Rodrigo this Philip the
Philippines
it was weird because I was like I was
like who's this girl at the White House
giving like a press conference about how
everyone needs to get the vaccine all
the young kids in the other needs to get
the vaccine and I was like oh [__] this
is their way to get like young kids to
go get the vaccine because I was like
who the hell is this chick like why
would you need a [__] charity concert
to go get back that's the way we wasn't
[__] [__] she wasn't safe that's a
different fee when everyone uses the
same lines right I always find that to
be indicative everybody's saying of some
of a successful maybe advertising
campaign like you're talking about right
but like one of my favorite ones is like
people get the vax they get the booster
and all that [__] and then they take to
Twitter to inform the world I I would
like to inform everyone that I have
coveted but I am so glad that I have the
vaccine or else it would have been so
much worse they all said the same exact
line or it would be so much worse do you
remember when they originally said if we
get vaccine do you remember when they
originally said if we get vaccinated
that we won't get covered exactly it's
crazy
[Laughter]